If there was water left, this line would have been the range of your ability.
300 liters of water can be manipulated at the same time
, but you can see that there are 3 types of water at the same time
So what should I do
?  Hey, you're a dummy The
only thing you're allowed to do is curse yourself for carelessly sticking your head in.
Do you think you have the same eyes as your friends?
The grooves are buried like the mesh of a net. The basis
for analyzing my ability was Omi
, so I should have paid attention to what you couldn't see
[Music]
Finally.  I don't have it, yeah, yeah, ani I've been
pouring
water all the way from the pond, right?
It's not a live show
Today's beads yeah yeah
me
ah ah ah